do you
do you feel like uh because you also
obviously you know going to school in
san diego do you feel like you kind of
heat it up there first yeah
definitely like because they [ __ ] with
you they [ __ ] with you
san diego yeah we did it i think we did
flux together yeah
it was pretty it was it wasn't like it
was like two years ago like
but like even before then like i was
doing clubs in san diego in 2015.
oh that's crazy yeah but like i was like
a whole different artist
like then like i was like doing like
trap [ __ ] like
yeah would you start just like get into
the melody [ __ ]
like when i was in atlanta i was just
listening to beats
and i came across uh papa
youtube and i heard uh the finance beat
and i was just like i'm at the same
like it's hard like i'm not homie was i
started playing like
and i started singing this [ __ ] and my
[ __ ] my roommate see lee
that [ __ ] came out of his room and was
like yeah that's
that's different that's it that's what
you need to be doing
and i was like yeah so the next day
after that i made atlanta
and we might have went to the club and
like his cousins and [ __ ] came maybe
some girls
like everybody we was chilling in the
spot and we was playing it
and it was like this [ __ ] hard like this
tight like
i was like yeah like y'all [ __ ] with
that [ __ ]
so like maybe like just throughout that
week i just started doing all kind of
beats like that
wow and that's how i came up with [ __ ]
too for real